guys how's it going just he didn't hear
me so I'm super excited because today
he's iPhone day and I slept in and I'm
afraid that I miss my I felt watching
this tomorrow or a week from now or a
month from now
today is September 21st 2012 hello
yeah the day of the iPhone 5 and I just
got right in the mail so excited
[Applause]
obsessed I need some scissors to cut me
the question I burn it should melt this
plastic a little bit I didn't even touch
you
so I'm gonna burn you please don't start
a fire some of you may know the last
time you had 4s came outs that there's
nothing in it his box was delivered with
nothing in it
so thank you let's take it out look it
out shall we
here it is
old phone new drone
we're gonna open it let's try to put
these in my ear so it happens configure
okay I will it is beautiful shining
shimmering splendid you put it in of
this away or add this away it's a little
bit taller should have been a baller
shot caller it looks great ah okay we're
all set up now it's time to use Siri
some girl to miss me I don't know what
that means
hey Siri are you better than you were
before I'm sorry I'm afraid I can't
answer that
hey Siri how excited are you about being
on the iPhone 5 hi
hey Siri I love you all you need is love
and your iPhone that is true okay thanks
so much for watching I'm to be playing
with my phone all day look for my new
freaking 720p front-facing camera let's
try that out real critical for if you've
ever used your old iPhone the
front-facing camera was not HD so I'm
gonna make a quick vlog and I'm gonna
post it on I just need I phone and you
guys have to let me know if it looks
better done I'm gonna go take a nap
cuz I just used up all my energy nah I
don't have you the shower when you came
because then I have to come out of the
shower to be naked new wings with
not here yet